hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute eine motiv torte
machen und zwar geht es um das thema
baby shower party und deswegen habe ich
mir eine zweistöckige motiv schotter
ausgedacht und setzt heute mit euch
zusammen machen
ich habe jetzt hier bereits einiges
vorbereitet ich greife einfach auf meine
grundrezepte zurück und hab hier
beispielsweise 220 jahren gebacken mit
dem hellen grund steigt und hier habe
ich vier 26er böden gebacken mit dem
dunklen schoko teig und hab da noch
leckere kirschen und rhein gegeben vor
dem backen und an zutaten brauche ich
außerdem noch etwas kirschwasser etwas
kirschsaft die sind nämlich von den
sauerkirschen ja aus dem glas noch übrig
den nämlich gleich zum trinken dann
traurig ein paar himbeeren
das sind 600 hier habe ich bereits eine
buttercreme vorbereitet dass es die
mango buttercreme das ist eine deutsche
buttercreme und hier habe ich noch
garage in zar peter und in weiß und die
genaue mengenangaben und wie viel ich
jetzt für dieses rezept genau benutzt
habe können wir dann einfach auf meinem
blog nachlesen
und ich stehe jetzt einfach direkt mit
der zusammensetzung der dunklen torte
das wird die untere etage und damit der
teig jetzt auf meinem kickboard nicht
hin und her rutscht nehme ich da jetzt
ein bisschen ganache und streicht es
jetzt auf das kate walsh
jetzt kommt auch direkt der erste boden
drauf
und den tränke jetzt mit dem kirschsaft
so wieder einfach noch fruchtiger und
etwas saft
ich setze jetzt auf eine tortenplatte
dann kann ich nämlich einfach damit
arbeiten und diesen schock gefühle ich
jetzt mit der vanille buttercreme
dann kommt jetzt der zweite boden drauf
und es wird jetzt einfach so lange
geschichte für sich alle vier teigboden
aufgebraucht haben
jetzt kommt noch der letzte boden drauf
und den setze ich jetzt verkehrt herum
auf damit ich oben die gerade oberfläche
ab und die torte packe ich jetzt in
etwas frischhaltefolie ein und stellt
sie kühlen
für die obere etage muss ich den teig
geht's erstmal durchtrennen
das mache ich jetzt mit so einer torten
säge
und das wird jetzt die helle torte mit
der mango buttercreme und mit den himmel
werden und da geht es jetzt genau
solchen das tegra streich etwas weise
ganache drauf
dann kommt der erste boden drauf und den
trinke ich jetzt mit etwas mangosaft
damit er auch einfach etwas feuchter
wird
da kommt jetzt auch ein drittel von der
mango buttercreme drauf
und die belege ich jetzt mit den
frischen himbeeren und da würde ich es
keine tiefgefrorene nehmen weil die
einfach beim auftauen dann zu wässrig
werden
und die torte wird es auch einfach so
weiter gestartet
und jetzt wird auch diese torte in
frischhaltefolie eingepackt und muss
dann in den kühlschrank und so lassen
sich beide torten über nacht erst mal
stehen dann kann die buttercreme schon
fest werden und ich kann sie dann morgen
mit ghanas bestreichen und fertigt die
torten waren jetzt beide über nacht im
kühlschrank und jetzt kann ich sie
weiter dekorieren und auch fertig
dekorieren und dafür muss ich die torten
ins essen mit garagen streichen und
damit ich das jetzt machen kann muss ich
die vorher so und bisschen zurecht
schneiden denn die torte schaut hier
rechts und links ein bisschen über
skateboard drüber weil das clipboard hat
25 cm und die torte hatte ja 26
zentimeter im durchmesser misst schneide
ich hier einfach am rand ein bisschen
was weg
und zwar mache ich das sitzen damit ich
gleich die ganz richtig schön glatt
drauf bekommen ohne dass ich später am
ende
buttercreme daneben mit draußen habe
also das später keine buttercreme an den
von doc und deswegen hier am kickboard
immer so 2 mm etwa ein bisschen
zurückschneiden wenn ihr müsst und dann
kann man sie später schön bestreicht
jetzt bestreitet die torte erst mal ganz
schön mit ghana
die torte muss jetzt erst mal in den
kühlschrank damit die erste schicht
jetzt fest werden kann und die krümel
gebunden werden und anschließend werde
ich sie dann komplett glatt streichen
und in der zeit kann ich schon mal die
zweite torte machen und die auf platt
streichen und dann ist sie eben auch
gleich wieder soweit
und wenn die erste schicht ist so
ungefähr 10 15 minuten gedauert
kommt jetzt die zweite schicht drauf und
wird richtig glatt gestrichen und es ist
dann die perfekte unterlage für unseren
von dauer
und den rest den nehme ich jetzt einfach
mit im nassen heißen messer weg
beide torten sind jetzt mit gage
eingestrichen und direkt beginnen und
die obere tor damit von dort eindecken
dafür habe ich mir jetzt hier weißen von
da ausgesucht und den muss jetzt erstmal
warten
jetzt wird er von dort noch dünn
ausgerollt so etwa auf 2 bis 3 mm und es
mache ich jetzt auch bäcker stärke damit
lebt und ich habe jetzt hier für die
obere torte 15 kilo von dort benutzt
jetzt soll ich denn von dort auf den
ausbau starb auf
dann hole ich direkt die torte her und
weil das da die oberfläche so trocken
ist gebe ich da jetzt ein bisschen backt
rinspeed raus dann wird die torte
nämlich wieder feucht und können sich
keine luftbläschen drunter bilden und
dann kann man denn von dort wieder
trüber aus rohr wieder von oben nach
unten glatt gestrichen erst die
oberseite und daneben die seiten
und die überschüsse nehme ich immer gern
mit einem marzipan messer
jetzt hätte ich noch die ränder und die
oberseite mit dem trockenen blätter
und mit dem werkzeug kann ich jetzt hier
die kanten noch ein bisschen eckig
klippen
heute ist jetzt völlig eingedeckt und
jetzt hole ich mir noch die schokotorte
und decke die auch ein
die unsere tochter möchte ich jetzt hält
können überziehen und deswegen für mich
jetzt hier dunkelgrün mit etwas geld und
dann wird es jetzt gleich halten
als einfach die sich kein pizzateig
bitte geh sie normal
ich kann nicht nein so genau mit der
handballer dass keine luft rein kommt
und habe ich luftblase letzte
auseinander machen eine kugel die luft
raus das ist kein oxidische spon land
jetzt machst zu einer kugel und jetzt
genau wann immer die kugel im kopf
hellwach
bitte mach ich dich mach nur
schaufenster muss ja ich weiss dass es
schwer ist es wege machst du es ja er
macht so was ja alle frauen und männer
die gempt hatte dekoriere hallo ich
glaube es reicht einmal die gleiche
menge machen was für ein name in die
macher auf das auszurollen eine kugel
was heißt die gleiche menge machen
machen
ok danke ich übernehme getan
jetzt wollte ich auch diesen von dort
hinaus und bedeckt dann noch die zweite
torte damit
ich möchte es noch die untere etage
etwas strukturieren und zeigte mir da so
ein paar streifen auto muss verein und
dafür habe ich jetzt hier ein geodreieck
das ist ganz praktisch denn wenn ich das
auflege habe ich ja hier automatisch
diesen 45 grad winkel
jetzt habe ich hier wieder dieses präge
werkzeug und kann da jetzt ansetzen
ich beginne jetzt mal unten
sie ist am limit fahren weil es ja keine
eckige sondern eine runde torte ist
also immer schön glatt ansetzen
jetzt habe ich hier den ersten streifen
jetzt könnt ihr euch ich hätte es
abmessen ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
vom geodreieck dieser parallelen und
setzt jetzt immer bei 4 cm einfach beim
vorherigen strich und kann dann hier die
zeichnung weiterführen
und jetzt setzt sich das geodreieck
genau andersherum an und beginne auch
unten an so einer ecke und jetzt wird
das ganze einfach noch mal in die andere
richtung gemacht
ich stecke jetzt noch die obere torte
und da habe ich vorhin einfach die
zwischenzeit gehen uns die wartezeit
genutzt und habe hier diese deko teile
hergestellt und wichtig gemacht hat
zeigt jetzt einfach kurz
ich habe jetzt hier bereits die
buchstaben ausgestochen und die blumen
und jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar
knöpfe formen und dafür habe ich hier so
eine tolle silikonform und zwar kann man
da ganz viele verschiedene sachen damit
machen
man kann zum einen schokolade einfüllen
oder eben auch mit blüten passte von
dort oder modelle schokolade diese
knöpfe formen und so mache ich das jetzt
ich habs jetzt schon ausgestoppt mit
oder bestäubt zudem hat immer sagt mit
etwas becker stärke jetzt nehmt ihr euch
immer kleine mengen habe ich schon weich
geknetet dann formt eine kugel die wir
dann da reingelegt man muss man immer
zuerst mal abschätzen wie viel brauche
ich überhaupt erst mal richtig schön
rein drücken und dann könnt ihr den
ersten überschuss so erstmal weg nehmen
mit einer palette oder mit einem messer
und den rest noch mal schön glatt formen
da fühle ich jetzt einfach mal alle
löcher aus und die muss man dann erstmal
so eine halbe stunde etwa antrocknen
lassen bevor wir sie dann aus der form
heraus nehmen dann verformen sie sich
nämlich nicht
nachdem an trockenen könnt ihr jetzt
auch die buchstaben etwas kontrollieren
und dafür präge ich sie wieder mit dem
pre gerat
jetzt werden die ganzen teile einfach
mit zucker kleber aufgeklebt
und jetzt werden noch mit zucker kleber
die blumen auf die grüne karte geklebt
zu sehen ist die einzelnen torten aus
und ich habe jetzt hier auch bereits die
schuhe hingelegt und zwar habe ich die
auch schon modelliert die könnt ihr in
einem separaten videos sehen also die
habe ich schon gemacht und jetzt muss
ich die torten einfach nur noch
zusammensetzen
jetzt können wir natürlich nicht einfach
die kleinere torte auf die große setzen
denn dann würde das gewicht der oberen
torte die untere eindrücken
deswegen brauche ich da halten wir ein
paar stützen und dann nehme ich jetzt
cake pops ticks dafür und die stecke ich
jetzt in die untere torte und kann dann
die zweite draufsetzen
dafür stehe ich jetzt den ersten stick
so etwa 5 cm vom rand hier ein bis ganz
nach unten dann markiere ich mir hier
diesen strich und weiß wo es abschneiden
muss und so schneide ich jetzt alle
sechs stäbe ab
jetzt mache ich mir hier einfach die
länge
mit einem lebensmittel stück und jetzt
kann ich die einzelnen städte
zurechtschneiden
jetzt könnt ihr einfach die stäbe
ringsrum reinsetzen und die bieten dann
den halt den wir für die torte brauchen
jetzt könnte einfach die obere torte
draufsetzen
jetzt ist es fast geschafft jetzt kann
ich da schon die schuhe draufsetzen
aber weil ich jetzt bei den schuhen auch
eine weise sohle habe und hier eine
weiße oberfläche habe möchte ich jetzt
hier noch ein bisschen puder anbringen
und zwar nehme ich da einfach diese
skizze bruder in blau und den weiß dass
streue ich jetzt hier direkt drauf und
kann das einem pinsel so ein bisschen
verstreichen
jetzt kann ich einfach draufsetzen und
da ist die torte nicht transportieren
werde weil die babyparty bei uns zu
hause stattfindet muss ich dir jetzt
auch nicht festkleben
aber wenn ihr die torte transportiert
müsst ihr auf jeden fall auch die zweite
etage ankleben einfach mit etwas ghana
oder mit iris zucker kleber dann klebt
die torte uhr auf der unteren pforte an
und die schuhe müsste eben auf die obere
torte ankleben
ich werde die torte jetzt bis zum
verteilen den kühlschrank stellen also
bis morgen
ihr könnt generell von antworten immer
in den kühlschrank stellen falls er zu
feucht sein sollte stellt einfach ein
schälchen voll mit salz daneben das
tätern die feuchtigkeit weg und ja ich
stelle die da jetzt rein bis morgen und
zeigt euch dann morgen auch noch mal im
anschnitt
nicht